is there symmetry there is symmetry the
be flashing clue is I've seen even power
even powers give you even symmetry right
like it's kind of a point of the name
okay so it's even symmetry once i graph
half of this I'll have the other half
that's great is it factorized it's it's
not I can't do anything to this this is
not difference of squares it's finished
okay there's nothing you need in there
another way you can see that by the way
is just think about what this bottom
thing is x squared plus one looks like
that right factorizing implies solutions
implies solutions this thing has no
solutions for when it's equal to zero it
never hits the axis so you cannot
factorize it at least not with real
numbers all right symmetry identified we
factorized it asymptotes we'll do the
easy one first vertical asymptotes come
from where where do they come from they
come from the denominator exactly right
when is this denominator equal to zero
answer it's never equal to zero so how
many vertical asymptotes do I have I
don't have any horizontal or oblique
yeah oh yes all right before I move on
to hell
yeah I don't think they're up because
the genetic copies here you should be
able put any value of x into that you
like it way let's finish this question
first yeah okay is it gonna be
horizontal or oblique horizontal very
good because the degree of the top is
0-3 of homes too so it's got to go
towards zero quick smart right it's
gonna get towards zero a quick smile so
there is my y equals zero horizontal
asymptote that's all the asymptotes
that's it saf3 just says right because I
can put in x equals zero and y equals
zero what happens when you do one over
this okay what's gonna happen when x
equals zero I just get one okay when you
get y equals zero yeah like was your you
tried that right and then you're like
uh-oh
when you cross multiply it's like oh oh
it breaks it breaks it doesn't have a
solution
so therefore what does that mean about
our x-intercepts there aren't any s a I
are four regions okay I didn't have to
put anything on this do i I don't have
to bring anything
cuz look at my factors one of them is a
number it's always positive and then
this guy is also always positive
so therefore my my total thing the whole
thing together is always positive that
again so therefore this is what I've got
looks a bit bad doesn't it okay don't
forget it's an even function so I'm just
gonna draw one part of it I'm going to
be there okay and then I have to come
toward this house into it but I can't go
negative because that's what my regions
tell me
what else can they do what else couldn't
do it can't for example it can't break
through the asymptotes because it just
told you we looked at the regions and
it'll never go positive right so must
approach there it can't come from
underneath okay is it going to go up
well if it goes up it's going to have to
go up on both sides it have to be this
weird like because it's an even function
right so it's going to have this it's
not going to be smooth and nothing about
the values actually tells you that right
yep why does it why does it go like that
little curvy did okay um okay because
when I take like these kinds of shapes
they're all they're all curved
right I don't have any straight lines
here I can't even when what I have is
like a linear function on the bottom
when you put it on bottom you get a
curved shape right so I know it must be
good I know I have to approach this
thing right so I can't no I can't do
this I can't do that because since I
really identified in step one it's an
even function but I would need this kind
of shape right but do you see that
sharpness see that sharpness at the at
the axis it's not smoothing it's not
curved right so therefore I can rule
that out the only way is I've got to
meet that in a nice gentle way okay
I really just said that um if I do this
it's an even function right so it's
gonna have to look like this but it's
not smooth so that's really the only way
I could get this kind of thing is with a
piecemeal function of some kind which I
don't have
and also this one five okay so I've got
one side so what does the other side
look like it's the reflection right
that's it
how do I work out horizontal asymptotes
how do we work out horizontal asymptotes
help me out guys you put in big numbers
because horizontal asymptotes are about
extremities they're bad extremities look
what what bearing what significance does
this horizontal asymptotes have to the
middle of the graph and sup nothing it
just goes away I don't care about that
guy it only tells you what's happening
at positive or negative infinity so in
order to get towards him you put in big
numbers I don't get you